one of my favorite things about uh Heart
of Stone is that we get to see you guys
bonding having fun you go to a bar you
drink beer and then you dance so I
wanted to know from you uh how is it
coming up with those scenes is it do you
have as much fun off screen as you do on
screen how it is I think we do I think
we do and that's what helps the scenes
uh you know play out better
um we had so much fun working together
uh they really enjoy working with me
[Laughter]
no but we really had such a immediate
chemistry that it helps everything we
feel very comfortable so the for this
for you for all of you I want to know
what are you most excited for people to
see in this movie I can start with you I
think um what I enjoyed the most when I
was watching and I watched the film like
an audience even though I'm in it
um it was a how it feels very personal
the whole you know
um the way the story unfolds it feels
like you're really there the camera
worked with the action sequences are
short also the characters you instantly
connect with Rachel Stone because of you
know she's sensitive she's not afraid of
showing her emotion but she's also
really tough and she's always you know
trying to help and save the day pretty
much and all the characters and their
arcs and their layers they all feel like
you you understand everyone and that's
what I like there's not just oh this is
a bad guy and this is a good guy and
this is a travel guy it's not it's not
that black and white I love the in
between and I mainly love the way it's
sort of shot like it just keeps going
like there's no break yeah it's true
what you do I just think the scale of it
and the ambition of it and hopefully
we've pulled that off you know where
we're we're taking people on a proper
ride here and partic you know right from
the off it was first 15 minutes are like
no you better be sort of ready for it
yeah it's very full on and hopefully uh
the whole movie feels like that you know
it's a very fun ride and we're excited
to offer that up to people okay what
about yourself I think the you know I'm
excited for people to sit at the edge of
their seats I'm excited for them to
reveal the the twists and turns I think
there's a really good healthy amount of
humor and action and drama and just for
people to enjoy it and and have fun with
us with the movie okay right uh so this
for the group as well I want to know
what do you like most about your
character his determination you know
he's very very driven he's very driven
and everything he does it's uh it's um
it can that's a good thing to sort of
aim for you know someone who who is sort
of focused on what they want to achieve
and we'll stop but uh any means to to
get there I admire that okay yeah what
about you her Humanity
um her ability to have an open mind
her
loose canon type of
[Music]
vibe that she has what she goes through
a lot right
okay so just have a couple minutes left
I don't want to ask you so I've been
having the product music video on
repeats
uh I love it
oh yes so I wanted to ask you uh is
there a big difference between working
in projects like bollywood's rrr the
master Alliance this is there a big
difference between them not really I
think a film set all over the world is
the same it's the same people it's the
same vision it's the same spirit it's
the same intention uh it's just the
language is different and eventually the
storytelling is also has to be not it's
not the same story telling but we're
working towards key core emotions
because that's eventually what connects
a universal audience so yeah yeah can
you tell us is there anything you can
say about red node is true maybe three
um we're all talking about it okay I
already I don't know
I don't know I don't know anybody can
say anything I already read the second
script oh wow
uh we're all that's the thing oh I'm
only making
dogs we're all very excited about it
okay so guys thank you so much thank you
so much